Michelle is with us in Pennsylvania
Michelle your question for dr. D and
myself yes hi
thank you for taking my phone call sure
my husband and I are both healthcare
professionals were higher performers in
our jobs and our salaries dictate that
my husband makes $100,000 a year and I
make 50 I'm part-time as a physical
therapist and the COBIT 19 has really
impacted the Philadelphia area immensely
his job is 100% stable because I deal
with elderly in nursing homes and
assisted living facilities that have
essentially shut down because of kovat
19 I'm uncertain from week to week
whether or not I will be furloughed or
not we have our house has been paid off
for the past five years and in the past
five years we've done things like we
there's new windows there's new siding
we don't have any credit card debt
whatsoever
I will be looking at the age of 65 and
having a $2,200 pension from a previous
job how old are you may have I'm 59 I'll
be 60 okay and we have I haven't looked
at the market because I'm scared to
death but but in February we had 1.5
million dollars saved in a 403b
account and what I'm experiencing right
now and I feel like I'm going to get
emotional I am so burned out I like I
have a lot of compassion fatigue and I'm
just really burned out and I told my
husband and I think that I really just
wanted to take a couple months off and
regroup and he has said to me you
shouldn't do that Michelle because if
they're going to furlough you then you
will get unemployment compensation and
you will also be able then to be able to
breathe a little bit better and also be
able to take advantage of unemployment
compensation the other people have a
million and a half dollars
about unemployment okay you're fine you
spent the last five years planning for
this moment
you have no debt no house payment your
husband's got a great job
you're millionaires you both help people
y'all are doing incredible work right
now you and what I love I love what I do
and I don't know how to get past the
compassion I don't want to leave the
people I serve but I don't know how to
do this so a hard thing for those of us
leave I'm gonna quit the people that I
love serving and so those of us who
serve other people for a living we often
find our identity we put our identity
and the ability to make somebody else's
day feel better and so what I'm gonna
ask you to do my friend Michelle I'm
talking to on the phone is to care about
yourself as much as you do your patients
and so we're in a situation now or your
patients the administrators have said
you coming in might do more harm than
good
and that's hard to hear somebody who
loves love's loves the people that you
get to help and then you get to be with
so I want you to take that energy and
focus it on Michelle and that means I
think you're making some smart decisions
about not looking at your numbers and
getting off the media and all that but
your identity's gonna be found in making
sure Michelle's okay right now let me
ask you something I mean ask both of you
something cuz I'm not sure I grasp this
but it occurs to me obviously you're you
are probably going to get furloughed
from doing PT and nursing homes I think
that's a fairly easy prediction okay
that's probably coming I'm surprised it
hasn't come already honestly because a
lot of places aren't allowing anyone in
a nursing home I don't know who's taking
care of them are you with your PT
training is there something you can do
in the middle of the actual kovat crisis
to assist the overload that some of your
other medical professionals are doing I
don't know if PT training set you up to
do that or not does it I if I worked for
a hospital system the answer would be
yes you can probably work for hospital
system by the end of the day if you
wanted to couldn't you
they're desperate I think they're
desperate for people taking temperatures
and that sort of thing it would be as a
volunteer so I I could do that I just
it just bothers me because I think that
people don't understand all the
secondary implications of quarantine
older adults with dementia and all the
second it like my husband said they're
busy as all get-out because everyone's
falling or tip fractures wrist fractures
there's no question but I think living
in a world where you're looking out to
say hey don't you see this is a big deal
I'm telling you right now we all we know
it's a big deal and the work you do with
the least of these in our communities
that forgotten people our communities is
it you're a human angel right and that's
that identities been polished right now
and that hurts and then you start
thinking well what am i worth what is my
value what about these people that I
love and what I'm asking you to do is to
sit down for a second and control the
things you can control and then like
Dave mentioned find other places where
you can surf you're a server at heart
that's who you are that's your wiring
it's awesome that you get paid for it
but you would do that for free because
that's who you are and so it's looking
at whether it's coming up with some
cheesy YouTube show and you can do PT on
the Internet's for P I don't know I'm
just making stuff up here but you're
gonna have to unhinge who you are from
this community here and to find places
to serve in your local area and the
person I want you to start with is
Michelle now I want you to start with
Michelle the good news is on my side of
this discussion you can afford it easily
easily we don't need to maximize your
unemployment but I mean if you hang
around another week you're probably
gonna be furloughed so you probably hang
on a week kiddo
but but at the end of the day do you
need to take a couple months off
somewhere in this process to reset white
board your life and go what do I want to
be when I grow up yeah why not you're a
millionaire your house is paid for your
husband makes 100 grand a year why not
and I would my good friend Lynn is a
she's a researcher in secondary
traumatic stress and it is real it's
heavy in it and it affects how you sleep
how you eat how you interact with other
people
and it's important that you come up with
a plan would you call that secondary
traumatic stress what's that mean that
means there's a trauma when someone gets
hit by a car right and there's a
secondary traumatic stress when you are
the EMS worker who is going all day
every day clear onto other helpless
challenges that's right or when you're
working with the health care provider
get secondary in a and it's profound in
its it's cumulative and it weighs on you
over time and that's where having a
relationships in your life that you
trust in a wellness plan that you stick
by religiously closed some sabbatical to
take care just some you know some time
off every week let me show you know this
right she's oh she's so Michele knows
this every every it just gets hard and
especially the heart of the fire gets I
was told at my last job John you have to
stop running into the building when it's
on fire we need you over here and when
you're wired like this like Michelle is
that's a special heart and she just
wants to bust in and it's hard for
health care providers and people who are
crisis responders to stop and I'm sorry
Frasier compassion fatigue before that's
an interesting phrase your body
registers the trauma in smaller amounts
but as though you're experiencing it too
and so trauma can be acute right away or
it can be cumulative and I always look
at Lincoln Coleman says ah you're not
burned out you're it's not burn out it's
build up he's exactly right over to
right and you can you can get a car
wreck and it's a cinder block or you can
show up to car wrecks and it's a pebble
over 15 years over ten years but that
wait is the same trauma is trauma is
trauma and you've got to again coming
back to you've got to connect with other
people that's your emergency fund for
those moments day so that's what those
of you who have health care
professionals in your life right now can
do is love them Wow love them let them
have let them have a sabbatical let them
have a Sunday off or whatever right and
or call them and tell them you love them
or Samael on their porch you need a
Sabbath you know you need a Sabbath put
a meal on the porch leave some flowers
whatever but just remind them that you
know because they need to get dialed
back away from that stuff enough too
set every 24 hours because then they're
heading back in that's right and we need
them we need them to go back our heroes
for sure yeah no question about it
it's wild out there well your phone
Michelle I love your heart Michelle I
love it and you guys have done such a
great job of money by the way everyday
millionaires you're okay financially
plan for this motif tell your husband to
breathe you need the unemployment I'm
all botches ears